what can we say what is the paper
that you're working on uh propose about
the ideas around these cortical micro
circuits
so this is a fully functional
model for the micro circuits of the
visual cortex
so the the paper focuses and your idea
in our discussions now is focusing on
vision yeah the uh visual cortex
okay yeah this is a model this is a full
model it says this is how fission works
but this is this is a model of scissors
here
okay so let me let me step back uh a bit
um
so we looked at neuroscience for
insights on
how to build a vision model right and
and and we
synthesized all those insights into a
computational model this is called the
recursive vertical network model
that we we used for breaking captchas
and and we are using the same model for
robotic picking
and uh tracking of objects and that
again is a vision system that's
coming to computer vision systems that's
the computer mission takes in
images and outputs what
on one side it outputs the class of the
image
and also segments the image
and you can also ask it further queries
where is the edge of the object where is
the interior of the object
so so it's a model that you build to
answer multiple questions
so you are not trying to build a model
for just classification
or just segmentation etc so it's a it's
a it's a joint model that can do
multiple things um and um so
so that's the model that we built using
insights from
neuroscience and some of those insights
are what is the role of feedback
connections
what is the role of lateral connections
uh so all those things went into the
model the model
actually uses feedback connections all
these ideas from you know from your
sites
yeah so what what what the heck is a
recursive cortical network like what
what are the architecture approaches
interesting aspects here
which is essentially a brain inspired
approach to
computer vision yeah so there are
multiple layers to this question
i can go from the very very top and then
zoom in okay
so one important thing constraint that
went into the model is that
you should not think vision think of
vision
as something in isolation we should not
think perception
as something as a preprocessor for
cognition
perception and cognition are
interconnected and so you should not
think of
one problem in suppression from the
other problem um and
so that means if you finally want to
have a system that understand
concepts about the world and can learn
in a very conceptual model of the world
and can reason and connect to language
all of those things
you need to you need to have think all
the way through and
make sure that your perception system is
compatible with
your cognition system and language
system and all of them and one
aspect of that is top-down
controllability
um what does that mean so that means you
know so
so think of it you know you can close
your eyes and
think about the details of one object
right i can i can
zoom in further and further i can you
know so think of the bottle in front of
me
right and and now you can think about
okay what the cap of that bottle looks
uh i know we can think about what's the
texture on that bottle
of the uh the cap you know you can think
about
you know what will happen if uh
something hits that
uh so you can you can you can manipulate
your visual knowledge in uh
cognition driven ways yes uh and so
this top-down controllability uh and
being able to
simulate scenarios in the world so
you're not just a passive uh
player in this perception game you you
can you can control it you can
you you have imagination correct correct
so so
so basically you know basically having a
generating network yeah
which is a model and and it is not just
some arbitrary generated network it has
to be
it has to be built in a way that it is
controllable top down it is it is not
just
trying to generate a whole picture at
once
uh you know it's not trying to generate
photorealistic things of the world you
you know you don't have good
photorealistic models of the world human
brains do not have if i
if i for example ask you the question uh
what is the color of the letter e
in the google logo you have no idea
although you have seen it millions of
times hundreds of times
so yeah so it's not our model is not
photorealistic
but but it is but it has other
properties that we can manipulate it
uh in the uh and you can think about
filling in a different color in that
logo
you can think about expanding the the
letter e yeah
you know you can see what in so you can
imagine the consequence of
you know actions that you have never
performed so so these are the kind of
characteristics the genetic model need
to have
so this is one constraint that went into
our model like you know so this is
when you read the just the perception
side of the paper it is not obvious that
this was a constraint into the
that went into the model this top
top-down controllability of the
generating model
uh so what what does the top-down
controllability
in a model look like
it's a really interesting concept
fascinating concept what is that
is that the recursive recursiveness
gives you that or
how do you how do you do it um quite a
few things it's like what what does the
model factor
or factorize you know what are the what
is the model representing us different
pieces
in the puzzle like you know so so in the
rcn
uh network it it thinks of the world you
know where i say
the background of an image is modeled
separately from the foreground
of the image so the objects are separate
from the background they're different
entities
so there's a kind of segmentation that's
built in fundamentally
and and then even that object is
composed of
parts and also and another one is the
the shape of the object
uh is differently modeled from the
texture of the object
got it so there's like these um
i've been you know who francois chalet
is
yeah uh yeah he's so there's uh he
developed this like iq test type of
thing
for arc challenge for and it's kind of
cool that there's um
these concepts priors that you defines
that you bring to the table
in order to be able to reason about
basic shapes and things
in the iq test right so here you're
making it
quite explicit that here here are the
things that you should be
there these are like distinct things
that you should be able to
uh model in this keep in mind that
you you can derive this from much more
general principles
it doesn't you don't need to explicitly
put it as oh
objects versus foreground versus
background uh
the surface versus structure now these
are these are derivable from
more fundamental principles of how
you know what's the property of
continuity of natural signals
what's the property of continuity of
natural signals yeah
by the way that sounds very poetic but
yeah uh so you're saying that's a
there's some low-level properties from
which emerges the idea that shapes
should be different than
exactly like uh there should be a parts
of an object there should be
i mean exactly kind of like friends of
water i mean there's objectness
there's all these things that it's kind
of crazy that we're humans
uh i guess evolved to have because it's
useful for us to perceive the world
correct yeah correct
and it derives mostly from the
properties of natural signals
and yeah and so um natural
signals so natural signals are the kind
of things we'll perceive in the
in the natural world i don't know i
don't i don't know why that sounds so
beautiful natural signals yeah
as opposed to a qr code right which is
an artificial signal that we created
humans are not very good at classifying
qr codes we are very good at saying
something is a cat or a dog but not very
good at you know
the classification computers are very
good at classifying qr codes
um so our visual system is tuned for
natural signals and there are
fundamental assumptions
in the architecture that are derived
from natural signals
properties i wonder when you take uh
hallucinogenic drugs does that go into
natural or is that close to the qr code
naturally it's still natural yeah
because it is still operating
using your brains by the way on that on
that topic i i mean i
haven't been following i think they're
becoming legalized a certain i can't
wait
until they become legalized to the
degree that you
like vision science futures could study
it yeah
just like through through medical
chemical ways modified there could be
ethical concerns but
modif that's another way to study the
brain is to be
be able to chemically modify it there's
probably um
probably very long a way to figure out
how to do it ethically
yeah but i i think there are studies on
that already
yeah i think so uh because it's it's not
unethical to give
uh it to rats oh that's true that's true
[Laughter]
there's a lot of drugged up rats out
there okay yeah cool
sorry sorry it's okay so there's uh so
there's these
uh low-level uh
things from natural signals that uh that
that
can from which these properties will
emerge yes uh
but it is still a very hard problem
on how to encode that again so you don't
you know there is no
uh so uh you mentioned um the the
the priors uh franchot wanted to encode
in uh
in the uh abstract reasoning challenge
but it is not straightforward how to
encode those priors
um so so some of those uh challenges
like you know the object
or completion challenges are things that
we
purely use our visual system to do it is
uh it looks like abstract reasoning but
it is purely an output of
the the vision system for example
completing the corners of that condenser
triangle completing the lines of that
concentric angle
it's a purely a visual system property
you know it's there is no abstract
reasoning involved
it uses all these priors but it is
stored
in our visual system in a particular way
that is amenable to inference
and and and that is one of the things
that we tackled
in the you know basically saying okay
these are the prior knowledge uh
which which will be derived from the
world but then how is that prior
knowledge
represented in the model such that
inference when when some piece of
evidence comes in can be
done very efficiently and in a very
distributed way
um because it is very there are so many
ways of representing knowledge
which is not amenable to very quick
inference
you know quick lookups and so that's one
um core part of what we tackled
in uh the rcn model um uh
how do you encode visual knowledge to uh
do very quick inference and
yeah can you maybe comment on uh so
folks listening to this and in general
may be familiar with
different kinds of architectures of
neural networks
what what are we talking about with rcn
uh
what are what does the architecture look
like what are the different components
is it close to neural networks is it far
away from neural networks what does it
look like
yeah so so you can uh think of the delta
between the model
and a convolutional neural network if
people are familiar with convolutional
neural networks
so convolutional neural networks have
this feed-forward processing cascade
which is called uh feature detectors
and pooling and that is repeated in the
in the hierarch
in a multi-level uh system um and
if you if you want to an intuitive idea
of what what is happening feature
detectors are
uh you know detecting interesting
co-occurrences
in the input it can be a line a corner
a an eye or a piece of texture
etc and the pooling neurons are
doing some local transformation of that
and making it invariant to local
transformations so this is what the
structure of convolutional neural
network is
um recursive cortical network
has a similar structure when you look at
just the feed forward pathway
but in addition to that it is also
structured in a way that it is
generating
so that again you can run it backward
and combine the forward with the
backward
another aspect that it has is
it has lateral connections these
lateral connections um which is between
so if you have an edge here and an edge
here
it has connections between these edges
it is not just feed forward connections
it is um something between these edges
which is the nodes representing these
edges which is to enforce compatibility
between them
so otherwise what will happen is the
constraints it's a constraint it's
basically
if you if you do just feature detection
followed by pooling
then your your transformations in
different parts of the visual field are
not coordinated
uh and so you can you will create a
jagged
when you when you generate from the
model you will create jagged
things and uncoordinated transformations
so these lateral connections are
enforcing
the the transformations is the whole
thing still differentiable
uh no okay no it's not it's not
trade using uh backprop okay that's
really important so
uh so there's this feed forward there's
feedback mechanisms
there's some interesting connectivity
things it's still layered
like uh yes there are multiple levels
multiple
layers okay very very interesting
you